在交易的世界里
每天都海量的资讯向我们砸过来
对吧
但问题是这里面哪些是根本没用的杂讯
而哪些又是真正能赚钱的讯号
今天我们就要来一步步拆解
如何建立一套系统
把这些混乱的资讯
变成一套有正期望值的量化交易蓝图
OK那我们就从一个最核心的心态开始聊起吧
你有没有想过
明明市场上的资讯
大家看到的都一样
为什么最后赚钱跟赔钱的结果
会差这么多
这张图说得很好
关键根本不在于
你能不能拿到什么内线消息
而是在于你怎么去转化
这些公开资讯
把它变成一套可以执行的策略
这就是大众跟交易者
思维上最大的分水岭
你看左边
这就是大众的反应
看到一个新闻
哇 这个题材好夯哦
然后呢
然后就没有然后了
就是一个情绪上的反应
跟着感觉走
但你看右边的交易者
他看到一样的新闻
脑袋里想的是
嗯 等一下
这个热度是真的吗
它背后的逻辑是什么
我能不能设计一个方法
来验证它
你看
这就是从被动接收
到主动出击的第一步
所以你看
我们整个过程
就像这个漏斗一样
非常形象化
我们的目标
就是要建立一套
可以重复使用的过滤系统
把市场上一大堆
充满情绪的故事
还有各种乱七八糟的杂讯
倒进这个漏斗里
然后一层一层的过滤
提炼
最后产出的
才是真正有价值
能帮我们把叙事
转化为获利的精炼策略
好 接下来我们换个脑袋
如果我跟你说
交易其实不是赌博
而是一门可以计算
可以规模化的生意
你觉得呢
任何一门生意
都有它的获利公式
对吧
交易也是
它的核心公式就是这个
你的总获利
等于你的胜率乘上风险报酬比再乘上你的交易频率当这整算出来的结果,也就是我们说的期望值1V大于0的时候,
恭喜你,
你做的就不是赌博了,
而是一个可以持续扩展的商业模式。
记住,
市场上从来不缺好听的故事,
真正稀缺的,
是数学上站得住脚的正期望值。
这张图可能要颠覆很多人的想法哦,
我们常常会陷入一个迷思,
就是觉得胜率越高越好
最好是百分之百
但你看胜率的回报
其实是有天花板的
你再厉害胜率了不起就是99%
但是风险报酬比呢
它的潜力是无限的
所以别在死磕那个80%的胜率了
你应该开始去设计那种
赔可能赔一块
但赚有机会赚一百块的
不对称赌局
这才是放大你期望值的真正关键
这个台风理论的比喻真的太贴切了
交易就像是方台
你觉得一场仗的输赢
是在台风登陆
风雨交加的时候决定的
还是在风平浪静的时候就决定了
当然是后者啊
你怎么不会等到台风都登陆了
才开始想说
我家窗户要不要盯起来
对吧
真正的胜负
在你开盘前
在你的研究阶段
剧本早就写好了
好理论讲完了
现在我们来点实际的
到底要怎么从茫茫古海中
找到这些值得下手的机会
这就是我们系统的核心
一个三英子的过滤器
我们要找的是一种市场失衡的状态
我们叫它隐形风口
简单说就是需求突然暴增
但供给跟不上
那怎么找就是靠这个黄金三奖
首先你需要一个叙事当作火种
点燃市场的想象力
接着你要用资金来验证
看看是不是只有你在嗨
还是真的有大钱进来了
最后再用基本面这个终极过滤器
确保这家公司是真的有料
而不是在讲空话
第一个因子叙事
重点来了我们要看的不是这个话题现在有多红而是它红起来的速度有多快这就像火灾警报器它不是在大火烧起来的时候才叫
而是在侦测到烟雾浓度开始变化的时候
就要像了
你懂我意思吗
我们要抓的是那个加速度
在趋势成为所有人都知道的尝试之前
就先进场
故事说的再好听
如果大钱没有进来
那都只是空谈
所以第二步就是要看大象的脚印
也就是大户的资金到底有没有在动
那怎么看呢
你可以去追踪ETF的净流入
看成交量是不是突然放大好几倍
或是看主力的买卖超数据
最要小心的就是图里那个红色警讯
明明题材很热
但资金却一直在跑
这通常就是有人在倒货给你
千万要小心
好 如果说叙事是季节
资金是雨水
那基本面就是最后要看
种子是不是真的有发芽
有长大
这是我们的最后一道防线
用来分清楚哪些公司
只是沾道边炒个话题的纯概念股
而哪些又是营收真的在加速成长
真正吃到这波红利的机油神
OK到这里我们已经透过三因子过滤器
找到了一个很棒的点子
也验证过了
那然后呢
光有想法没用啊
重点是怎么把它变成一套
可以重复执行的行动计划
这张图就把我们整个系统的蓝图
从头到尾都画出来了
你看
就是一个完整的生态系
从最一开始的资讯输入
到用逻辑跟数据去过滤
然后产出一个有正EV的策略剧本
接着透过一套标准流程
去执行你的部位
而这所有的一切
都建立在最底层的心法
也就是纪律之上
讲到执行
最忌讳的就是一把锁号
那是在赌博
专业的做法绝对不是靠胆量
你看这个流程图
它的核心精神就是
先试探再确认后加码
我们先用一个小部位去测试市场的水温如果市场的反应证明我们想的是对的我们才加码如果感觉不对劲那就赶快闪人控制亏损
记住你的大部位是市场给你的
不是你猜出来的
系统流程都有了
但最后也是最难的
其实是我们自己这个人
如果没有对的心态去执行
再好的系统再好的策略
最后都会是一场空
这张图的方法真的超赞
它教你怎么刻意的去反人性
什么意思
对于每一次的小亏损
你要拿放大镜去看
让自己感觉到痛
这样你才会记得要守纪律
但反过来
当你赚大钱的时候呢
你要拿望远镜
远远的看
告诉自己
就这样
保持平常心
千万不要因为赚了一大笔
就得意忘形
破坏了自己
好不容易建立起来的系统
这个应该是所有交易者最大的心魔了
叫做部位偏见
你看明明是同一张K线图
为什么会有人觉得是回挡
有人觉得要崩盘
有人在犹豫
有人在窃喜
因为你的部位决定了你的视角
你手上有股票
你就会帮他找理由
所以唯一的解法就是
练习在看盘的时候
把自己口袋里的钱忘掉
假装自己是个空手的路人
这样你才能客观的看市场
OK,讲了这么多,我们来做个总结,把今天所有的精华浓缩成一张检查表,还有一个最重要的心法。
我的风险控管有没有避开情绪陷阱,
把这个流浅走完,
你的决策品质就会大大提升。